Steven Spielberg is taking a serious
stand against cancel culture the
Hollywood Legend thinks Classic Movies
should not be changed for modern woke
audiences who get offended by every
little thing and he even regrets doing
it himself after making a change to his
Blockbuster E.T
I know at one point you took some guns
out of E.T and then regretted it that
was a mistake that was a mistake um I
never should have done that because ET
is a product of its era and it's not no
film should be revised based on the
lenses we now are either voluntarily or
being forced to peer through
you know I was so impressed Dana with
how Spielberg talked about it he said
it's a signpost of where we were what
the world was like what world what the
world was receiving at the time and yet
he still made the change but is cancel
culture changing well I wondered if he
has he been canceled this afternoon I
lost track I hope not I think it was
refreshing what he said but I also think
we could apply that wisdom to all sorts
of other things for example when we're
tearing down statues all across America
and trying to rewrite history in a way
that would be what we would normally say
it's interesting actually I just thought
of this so not long ago I listened to a
classic book that I had read years and
years ago by Ernest Hemingway and I had
read it a long time ago and now I was
listening to it on Audible and I'm
walking along and I'm like okay oh wow I
can't believe they actually used that oh
and that word too and it was just like
one of those things but I didn't judge
it as a way to say oh he's a terror what
a terrible person he was did he say gosh
darn no I mean I'll tell you when the
break
what he said because I don't want to get
canceled
well you know what it but but but isn't
rewriting the past one of the most
dangerous things we're doing in terms of
history and uh but also it I think they
realize it can't work because like they
there was a moment in time when they
were treating guns like cigarettes maybe
we can get them out of the movies but
you realize guns if you remove guns from
movies there's no movies right it is
integral to the plot unlike cigarettes
although Alec Baldwin should stick to
romantic comedies I have a theory we
work in cable news right where people
are auditing every word we say and yet
we still show up and take risks and jump
off a cliff that's in Hollywood they
don't even have any opposition right the
only opposition for them taking a stand
is their own fear of not belonging they
all obey they all stay on the flock and
that's the irony of this is that
Hollywood portrays their celebrities as
very edgy but they're all wimps they're
all wimps they never take a stand about
anything and who's going to cancel them
yeah nobody it's a single industry and
speaking of cowards take a listen to
this sound
oh there's no sound oh okay there's no
sound this is Molly uh Ringwald
criticizing cancel culture she says a
lot of people have gotten swept up in
cancellation and I worry about that it's
unsustainable some people have been
unfairly canceled and they don't belong
in the same category as someone like
Harvey Weinstein well she's exactly
right uh and you know to that I say
welcome to the fight to Stephen
Spielberg but the idea you know the idea
that he's going to speak up to defend
his movies and I think some of the
movies are great but some of them are
sort of irrelevant or whatever but but
after standing by and watching you know
hundreds of years of statues being
destroyed in this country
um and defaced like some sort of weird
modern American Isis
um Wrecking cities and Wrecking uh
monuments I think is uh you know I think
it's kind of selfish and a little late
to the game yeah and it doesn't reflect
who we were at that time right so what
do you think is cancel culture leaving
us
I think it is a little bit honestly I'm
seeing that in the data that I look at
even with younger generations with Gen
Z's and Millennials they're becoming
more moderate in it because they also
want to accomplish things you want to
get things done and it's part of why
everyone ended up getting on board with
Joe Biden they thought okay well maybe
this guy will get things done and
they've actually been overwhelmingly
pleased with the agenda items
what yes you know they voted for Joe
Biden to get rid of cancer culture that
is no I'm talking about being more
moderate in in your in your policy
positions and in your life and saying
things like maybe I was wrong to say
that Al Franken Harvey Weinstein and
Matt Lauer in the same conversations
obviously those are patently absurd
comparisons and that's where we were at
the beginning of the metoo movement
where it was just every man that may
have reap from raping someone to imit to
going like this and not even touching
someone's breasts
was elected I'm just I can't follow this
argument well I'll explain it to you in
the break because it is all connect
anyway Steven Spielberg though can do no
wrong I think and that's why it's good
for him to be having these conversations
not a good not one bad movie I think he
can do no wrong in conversations I don't
I mean I guess
come on how long do you want to go
what's your favorite Spielberg movie
I don't want to say Jaws
um they don't we have all right
everybody hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else